you love sports now it seems to be like
something you really love do you really
really love it do you love just the
gambling do you love sports yeah so I
always love sports I love gambling right
obviously it's what we do now so that
worked out like before I started
Barcelona I was trying I want to get
into that industry right yeah I flew out
to Vegas tried to do all the stuff so
it's worked out perfectly for me and
probably like one of the few guys who's
made money through gambling most people
get wiped out
um so yeah no I'm a big sports fan and
obviously it's been a core part of what
we do so it makes me like I'm not
uh maybe I'm not getting arrested and
going to jail if we're not doing
Barstool I'm not like that crazy if I
was just sitting around as a normal fan
okay um but I love sports yeah Boston
Sports guy through and through do you
think that they should have legal
gambling like everywhere because none of
you guys work with your gambling site is
under digital Sports Social Sports Book
okay sports book yeah and they even have
bars like I was in Baton Rouge and they
have like a barcel Sportsbook bar in the
casino yeah yeah because so we were
bought by a company called pen and they
have uh L'Auberge we also have like
Standalone so we're actually getting one
here in Nashville like yeah there'll be
a barcel sports bar it's where like the
old uh Joe's Crab Shack used to be so
it's a good spot
um
so I think it will eventually go Most
states but it it so gambling became
legal to bet on Sports outside of Vegas
maybe two years ago two and a half
something like that they repealed some
federal law and now it's up to the
states so they just decide state by
state so I think we're live in like
maybe 11 or 12 States and do you Lobby
for that somehow or you just that's just
let the world do that our parent company
lobbies for it and all the different
companies that are involved in that
Lobby for it and there's people Lobby
against it so I have nothing to do with
it but yeah there's a lot of politicking
going around it with that do you get
more joy out of making like a big wager
on one thing or hitting like a crazy
parlay you know I don't do as much as
parlays so like bet on one thing winning
it I mean I I bet my whole life so it's
just but yeah not it's I love it I love
gambling yeah you like to gamble like do
you feel like that that's just like a
thing you like to do just with sports or
even like kind of with everything like
you kind of like to go kind of like the
alternate route a little bit yeah yeah
it's I definitely even Barstool like I
think being an entrepreneur kind of is
like gambling different different
respect but I saw barcel with nothing
really and everything we made we put
back into it for the most part work but
you know we did concert I thought we
were going out of business at one point
because I put all our money into like a
concert tour and it kind of food was it
like Third Eye Blind or something no
believe it or not so we did this thing
it we had never left downtown Boston
ever and and I was like all right we
gotta see if we're big outside of Boston
and we had liquor sponsors at the time
and they were like well you know we
can't sponsor you if you're going to
colleges and we're like well what if we
make it a Music Tour could you they said
yeah so we had this kid Sam Adams
um it kind of blew up and he's got some
big songs we did it we did six six stops
and it went really well
um bigger than we ever thought and I I
looked at it so we originally thought
we're going like frats and you we go to
UMass and this the actual School calls
like Hey we're again all these requests
for tickets what is this so we went from
the Frat to the actual like Mullen
Center which is the gymnasium sold out
in a second my brain's going the
business side's like hey if I can
recreate this with like big talent I may
be on to something so we had a Music
Tour it was headlined uh by Mike Posner
do you remember like cooler than me at
the time I saw Mike two weeks ago yeah
so that song just came out he was the
headliner it was uh him Wale I had Mac
Miller for 1500 bucks that's how much we
were paying him to play so he was the
third guy coming up on it uh and nobody
[__] bought well people bought
tickets same amount as the first time we
went around it turned out our crowd they
weren't coming necessarily for who we're
booking they're coming because barcel
was on it oh wow we got [__] wiped
out I actually hated posing he didn't
promote the [__] he didn't promote it at
all not his fault his age's fault
um so that was a disaster and then we
moved from that because it was kind of
like all right if people are coming for
bar stool not the talent doesn't really
matter and we went into EDM so you lost
you lost your butt on that smoked
because you had to pay the act so much
pay the accent I rented the buildings so
we were going I was paying like Yeah The
Vig on that building like 200 Grand or
something a night and we weren't doing
it I thought I was gonna have to pay the
full thing we had to cancel a lot of the
shows
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one